s'affranchir d'une partie de ses
engagements pris dans le cadre du brics
it
voilà l'objectif derrière cette nouvelle
manoeuvre politique de londres alors que
les deux parties sont entrées en début
de semaine dans leur dernier cycle de
négociations
l'impatience des britanniques a coupé
les ponts avec leur ancien allié irrite
les hauts responsables européens très
préoccupé par les annonces du
gouvernement britannique sur ses
intentions de violer l'accord de retrait
cela enfreindrait le droit international
et saperait la confiance pacta sunt
servanda le fondement de relations futur
prospère
l'allemagne demande des explications la
france elle se prépare à tous les
scénarios
cette manoeuvre politique fâche l'europe
toute entière mais pas que au sein même
du parlement britannique boris johnson
est bousculé par des députés qui
dénoncent aussi cette décision cette
législation est contraire au droit
international mais l'emprunt également
le droit national
le premier ministre et ses amis une
bande de voyous sont en train de créer
un état voyou un état ou l'état de droit
ne s'applique pas pourquoi le premier
ministre pense-t-il que lui et ses amis
surtout dessus de la loi bien au
contraire monsieur le président ce
projet de loi britannique sur le marché
intérieur vise à protéger des emplois à
préserver la croissance
assurer la fluidité et la sécurité de
notre marché intérieur et la prospérité
dans tout le royaume uni
il devrait être bien accueilli je crois
en écosse en irlande du nord au pays de
galles et dans tout le pays londres est
donc déterminé à mettre en oeuvre ses
projets quitte à accentuer les tensions
avec l'union européenne
une décision qui rapproche encore un peu
plus les deux parties d'un odile alors
pourquoi ce projet de voir présenté par
le gouvernement britannique provoque une
telle controverse au sein de l'europe
éléments de réponse avec 400 brillant et
la salle off alors que l'union
européenne est en colère le gouvernement
de boris johnson ne cache pas ses
intentions
le dernier projet de loi révisant partie
les engagements britanniques pris dans
le cadre du breakbeat
en violation du droit international ce
texte concerne le marché intérieur du
pays plus précisément le processus qui
va permettre aux quatre nations qui
constitue le royaume uni l'angleterre
l'ecosse le pays de galles et l'irlande
du nord de commercer sans entrave
alors quelle est l'origine de la
controverse qui a provoqué la colère des
dirigeants européens
ce projet de loi présenté par le
gouvernement de boris johnson modifie
notamment le protocole nord-irlandais
visant à éviter le retour d'une
frontière physique sur l'île à la fin de
la période transitoire en décembre
l'irlande du nord a son propre statut au
sein de l'accord destiné à conserver
ouverte en toute circonstance sa
frontière avec la république d'irlande
membres de l'union européenne
le nouveau texte permettrait au
gouvernement de mettre de côté la
commission mixte dans certaines
circonstances et de prendre des
décisions unilatéralement sur des sujets
relatifs au commerce avec l'irlande du
nord et l'impact des aides d'état dans
la région
si le premier ministre anglais parlent
d'un filet de sécurité juridique l'union
européenne à elle rapidement averti le
royaume uni que toute remise en cause
des termes du divorce empêcherait la
conclusion d'un nouvel accord sur leurs
relations futures